now this is the next great frontier
we've done pretty well over the last
century or so to generate prophylactic
vaccines that is vaccines that prevent
infectious diseases smallpox has been
pretty much eradicated throughout the
world polio is almost non-existent
months rubella etc there really are
diseases of the past but what we've now
learnt about how the immune system works
are we in a position to ask the immune
system to recognize what we will call a
self protein that is one that doesn't
belong to an infectious organism our
body generates proteins all the time
that our immune system has evolved as we
grow up to recognize those proteins
ourself and doesn't mount an immune
response against them however one can
envisage the Alta trip immune system to
recognize some of these proteins as
being formed so proteins that we
associate with disease we may want to
remove from the body via the immune
system so some examples would be as you
mentioned Alzheimer's disease we know
that in Alzheimer's disease there are
proteins which are made or cause the
disease which we will call aberrant
proteins they've been somehow changed
from the normal type of protein and
because they've been changed the immune
system can now see that they are
different from normal physically bind
those proteins and remove them from
circulation and indeed there have been
clinical studies targeting Alzheimer's
causing proteins and indeed there has
been clinical benefit derive from the
reduction of these aberrant proteins as
a result of the vaccine so whereas it
might sound a little bit far-fetched
because most people associate vaccines
with pediatric or infective infant
diseases and preventing infectious
diseases we can envisage how we could
harness the
immune system to manage certain diseases
which are causing real problems in the
developed world
another area that we're looking at doing
what we call therapeutic vaccines that
is to treat the disease as opposed to
prevent the disease and that would be in
cancer a cancer has some similarities to
infectious disease because cancers arise
from the genetic changes that are
ongoing in our bodies all the time which
generate what we call tumor antigens
that are associated with tumor cells and
cancers are effectively arising from
cells where their normal state is no
longer maintained and they grow
uncontrollably and associated with these
uncontrolled cells are known are
associated with known tumor antigens and
by targeting these tumor antigens for
the immune system via vaccine we can see
that the immune system can kill these
tumor cells and treat the cancer so
whereas we're early days in the realms
of cancer we do see encouraging progress
being made in the clinic we've had 20
odd years of abject failure in cancer
vaccines but once again as we understand
how tumors are able to evade the immune
system and how we can now more
specifically up regulate the immune
system we believe that we can help the
immune system also cure us from cancer
vaccines have been with us for gosh
hundreds of years when we look back to
small smallpox vaccines and they really
have been the spine the main route for
public health management vaccines
prevent infectious diseases and do so
very efficiently however there's still
some infectious diseases which have been
resistant to us to be able to generate a
vaccine and some of the ones that you're
all familiar with like HIV tuberculosis
malaria each of those organisms have
managed to generate mechanisms with
which to evade the human immune system
and yet these diseases have tremendous
toll on human life and morbidity so
whereas we have been successful for many
infectious diseases at least those three
diseases still require very innovative
and different ways of thinking about
generating a vaccine and for each of
those areas encouraging progress is
being made both at the research level
and also the clinical development level
whether those clinical development
programs are being run by a
biopharmaceutical companies or by
non-government organizations encouraging
progress is being made certainly against
malaria and certainly against TB now we
move beyond infectious diseases and
preventive vaccines for those and start
to think about therapeutic vaccines and
vaccines to treat disease then that
opens up a whole new Vista and what we
have learned about the immune system
certainly gives us encouragement that we
can generate very specific and hopefully
expect Phylly safe ways of being able to
harness the immune system to take out
aberrant proteins that are associated
with disease and then again there's
encouraging progress on this front only
last year that vaccine to manage
hypertension
showed very encouraging results in the
clinic where a vaccine generated against
a protein called angiotensin 2 was
successfully reducing its concentrations
in the circulation rating system and as
a result blood pressure reduction was
achieved so very encouraging progress
that we can target human proteins self
proteins reduce their concentration and
generate the desired clinical benefit so
I think there's great scope for
therapeutic vaccines as an alternative
modality for managing disease in the
future
that's a really difficult question
because there are so many diseases which
have such high mortality such high
mobility HIV is still a tragic disease
malaria has some of the highest
mortality rates for any disease in the
world tuberculosis then you look at
Alzheimer's and the morbidity associated
with that rheumatoid arthritis all those
diseases require cost-effective easily
accessible means of etta disease
management and certainly one can
envisage vaccines playing an important
role in managing those diseases in a
different way than we can currently so
if I were to pick one I probably would
have to go with malaria simply because
the death toll from that on a weekly
basis far outweighs any of the other
infectious any other diseases